boom bootleg podcast special guest my
good friend dog ritz
my dog what's up buddy well first of all
as i've been telling you since i've been
here man i'm so proud of you this is
[ __ ] crazy
dude i watch your interviews all day
like everybody you're doing like uh man
dude i'm so proud of you man you're
killing it kev actually let me rap um
i think the chief keith record
2012. yeah and i don't know where we
were we're in phoenix oh okay yeah yeah
but dude you're killing me bro
thank you for still being my friend of
course after all this fame and fortune
and i really appreciate it
and after you know just getting to know
you as an actual human being and still
deciding you know i'm still associate
with this guy
like yeah that's kind of up in the air
like right it's like hey maybe not um
thank you sweet jacket
and the same with me oh yeah well
it's a hell of a jacket you got on
it's a do you want a jacket
it's like if you're going to do a jacket
oh that's a do you want a jacket jacket
you want jack do you want a jacket
jacket do you want a jacket jacket yeah
now you know what it is though i swear
to god this [ __ ] works been playing
these crowds on his tour man when you
get a shiny ass jacket especially
michael jackson has such an impact even
if you're fat red-headed and all that
[ __ ] you get a fly-ass jacket it's crazy
y'all come out on stage and then and
they want a jacket
well they just look and they they want
to jack they probably do they want to
jack you off most of them are men but
unfortunately most of them are men that
have
b.o and hatchet man tattoos yes yes but
me and me and my dj chris crisis we have
a um we do have a thing no like when i
take my jacket off he does a little
no no no no no i i saw that today yeah
yeah
yeah yeah shout out to chris crisis hell
of a tour dj yeah oh yeah yeah for sure
but good with the figgity figgities oh
that's my dog man i love him to do with
the wicked wicked brother he can scratch
his ass off yeah he's he's my brother um
but yeah as far as the jacket goes like
i heard he's got a big dick too anyway
continue
you said that that's what you said
chris christie
this guy's never seen his dick chris
says don't you brag about how big your
dick is
are you just telling the truth no no you
got to cut yo
word on the street okay gotta get crisis
so much play right now come on camera
and talk about your dick real quick
chris
no yeah he's done he's good that's what
happens to bumpers with a big deal they
don't they don't need all that yeah
kickstand chris over there doesn't want
to get on camera yeah no thanks i don't
have to talk about it you want to see it
see it in real life yeah there's my dick
yeah i'm on tour 67 more days no way we
don't need to make this motherfucker's
head any bigger of us any bigger than it
literally is
[Music]
let me ask you something yeah
you're
dude i can't believe i'm here by the way
kev i i've been watching you i've been
stuck i've interviewed you a million
times i know but like man you're you're
like a huge celebrity now man i'm you
know what's crazy do you remember the
night the worst night of my life you
were there when i ate edibles
oh yeah you flipped your [ __ ] and you
flipped out you pulled a ritz i
interviewed you on the bus
and miss dimples was there and we were
hanging out and i was like bro i was
like bro i ate i ate an edible i don't i
don't even remember
like i didn't it didn't hit me but you
went on stage
and i lost my [ __ ] mind dude you know
what's crazy i tell the story all the
time because it's the worst night of my
life you know what's crazy about that is
is like like me having anxiety or like
man i used to be like
you know not to be like lame as hell
everybody smokes weed but i used to be
like snoop dogg back in the day i could
smoke you know i get mad at somebody
rolled down the window but as i got
older [ __ ] made me paranoid
and i i smoke now [ __ ] i'm high right
now you know what i'm saying but it's
like
your [ __ ] ass i felt bad for you bro
because i had way too much edibles and i
was hallucinating bro you were
performing
and i'm in the crowd
lifted next to me my best friend geo's
next to me
i couldn't move my legs i felt like they
were planted in the floor and you were
sitting next to you on stage
was garfield the cat
with with with slot machine eyes i know
when you came backstage and talked to me
afterwards i was puking outside sorry i
was puking outside
i was throwing up and then all the wild
[ __ ] that could have happened to someone
while being a tripping ball has happened
like some native american dude came up
to me in the [ __ ] alley and was like
telling me about his driving [ __ ] i
thought he wasn't even there but he was
really there so get the [ __ ] away from
me and then yellow and then yellow
wolf's [ __ ] tour manager brooklyn
beat the living [ __ ] out of some dude
right in front of me while i'm tripping
balls
this was a club
this is club red in tempe arizona duke
can i tell a story about brooklyn real
quick that's a funny one um
not the one just don't tell the stories
out earlier no no no no not that but
like like you know so i don't ever get i
was telling you earlier like people
don't ever ask me questions like that i
really like to share that i think my
fans would like to hear right
so brooklyn and i don't want to knock
this guy in this city because i'm a cool
[ __ ] man i respect the local
rapper right so we're at this local show
in florida right there's this crew of
rappers
and they're doing that thing and i'm
trying to get
be cool with the local guys because i
respect them you know what i'm saying
especially they're deep and all that
[ __ ] not even knowing oh no tough [ __ ]
just trying to be cool with them so i'm
shaking their hands while they're doing
all that so i do that do the meet and
greet i come back about four or five
hours later and these guys they did
their set they probably got otter home
he's out there feeling themselves you
know what i'm saying they're having a
great time which if i could have opened
up for a me or whoever back then you
would have
either way i would have been having the
best night of my life so this guy was
feeling himself so much my ass gets up
on there hey yo and shout out to all the
[ __ ] openers in this [ __ ]
everybody struggling trying to rap this
dude gets up on stage oh that's me
brooklyn comes out bam [ __ ] them up
dude kicked them so hard in the back yo
that [ __ ] brooklyn did not play
i felt so bad for the kid man he was the
main guy but yeah i mean dude i'm not
calling out no names i don't even
remember and shout to you for what city
in florida was this i don't know one of
them crazy ass white boy would go t city
all of them yeah all of them yeah you
know i'm right away i'm in you know in
atlanta the same [ __ ] but uh
wow man i felt bad for the guy brooklyn
came in and like high out his ass oh
yeah i was talking about earlier too i i
actually got in a fight one time but i
let i did some bitch-ass [ __ ] and i let
brooklyn start it and i just jumped in
and got some cheap ones
i walked away with a limp
afterwards i was like man yeah i
shouldn't i shouldn't be doing that [ __ ]
um
you know what's crazy about florida is
you when i first moved to florida
you and jelly roll did a concert you had
some random ass hotel probably no no
i drove to orlando
oh okay you guys had a random ass show
in orlando and this is the first time i
ever met jelly roll that's when we
that's when you heard the chief jinx
when he was in the hotel
yeah yeah when he played me his white
floor right at me yeah yeah yeah
boy yo if y'all don't know there's a
rapper named chief jinx hottest [ __ ] in
the streets so like if you like ll cool
j and flow rider but but janet dick but
that chief is my boy and he i love chief
by the way i love chief one of my
favorite people i was a little
disappointed he wasn't on tour with you
yeah yeah i was too but that would be no
if you like slow rider low and pitbull
but you're looking for the white version
of that chief jinx me and you were
walking through the [ __ ] streets
chris chris's favorite guy go ahead no
but i remember that me and you were
walking through the streets and
by the way kev's a wild man so anybody
that watches his interviews and like
i said that to somebody like wild man
nah nah i mean much respect his family
and everything else but like um
kev's a [ __ ] maniac so like anytime
people are like yeah dude like caviar
interviews everybody knows dude's a [ __ ]
he's the rapper [ __ ] we're just
sitting here he's the part of you so
anyway anyway no but um yeah where was
it yeah we were in orlando yeah and that
night
you i is the first night i met jelly and
then i end up
at mike busey's sausage castle so you
were at my room we talked about what to
expect at the start and you were like
bro i'm not going to go you go though
trust me you're going to want to go okay
can we do this real quick because this
is a good moment to do this
to my wife
i did not go the sausage castle no you
stayed back i sent him because i didn't
want to partake
yes this is awesome thank you for giving
me this validation no yeah you stayed at
the room because i didn't want to do it
but i warned you what she was about to
deal with it was like you're like bro
you should go it'll be fun and i and i
would like to go as an outsider but i
ain't want to get in trouble man my mike
bucy man shout out to him and that
[ __ ] is amazing so we end up
yeah what happened so listen this is the
first so so mike busey is gary busey's
nephew cousins whatever right yeah by
the way my beauty to this day is my boy
like we talk a lot so great guys that's
my guy one of the most giving
open-hearted humble dudes ever so he has
even though he doesn't look at the time
i meet this dude at the show and i'm
like who's this goofy-ass white dude
with the crazy hair and the tattoo with
belly with random [ __ ]
with your balls showing yeah and you're
like bro listen he's got this house you
got to go
so i just moved to florida and i'm like
[ __ ] it let's get into some florida [ __ ]
so i go over to mike i go over to my
busy's house it's literally on the swamp
in the middle of [ __ ] florida
outside of orlando look jealous too
because i was sitting there like why
didn't this house is like
the house of a thousand corpses
meets
juggalos meets the playboy mansion yeah
yeah so there's a fish tank with dildos
in it
this is like five years ago this is this
is the old house so he's got a new house
now yeah this is 2014.
yeah it's a long time ago okay
yeah he had a [ __ ] drill with a dildo
at the end
this [ __ ] had a stripper pole he
had glory holes throughout the house oh
my god pocket pussy's installed in the
wall here's how lame i am i couldn't
wait to talk to him about his experience
outdoors he's got a giant bro he's got
all these machine guns he's got pigs
alligators pugs
[ __ ]
all kinds of [ __ ] and the first time i
meet mike busey
he is like the most like loving dude
ever right he's a great guy and i don't
know him that well but i know him enough
to like i got love he bro he's so she
starts showing me these sex tapes he has
because his whole house is like filmed
at all times so he's like yo check out
this sex tape of me and random white
rapper with a bunch of tattoos a and
random white rapper with a bunch of
tattoos b
three-way in this [ __ ] hey you know
what i'm going to tell you this i'm not
going to say who they were no go ahead
go go go go go ahead no cause you might
have been expanding on that no go no no
i'm done i will say this though i i
don't like i was telling crisis this
when a guy's like hey i was having a sex
tape and it's just their little it's
just their wayner going it's like a
point of view was that pov i don't want
to see your dick going in and out
[ __ ] i want to see like you want
to see the [ __ ] plus it's awkward like
oh that's great a [ __ ]
jose like
this crazy bastard this guy's a [ __ ]
maniac he is a maniac straight up this
guy is like what was it point of view or
no he was showing no it was surveillance
footage oh yeah so you saw like
and they're like high-fiving and like
i hate that weird [ __ ] where it's like
hey here's me and it's just like just a
bunch of dick going in in and out of
vaginas tons of dick yeah now he's not
answering it's in fl he's in florida so
what time is it
it's like we don't boot like kev time
right now remember tonight
my bootleg goes all night man it's
[ __ ] on some dope
yeah he just texts me the other day
he'll call
i just told him what we're doing he's
like i'm gonna wake up for this his
ringer was probably off he'll probably
call back dude he does a [ __ ] do you
know every veteran's day
he has some chick named jenny jizz at
the sausage castle
jenny jizz at the sausage castle nice
and this [ __ ] mike busey invites
all veterans to his house this fool will
have like two or three hundred veterans
at his house and this jenny jizz [ __ ]
sucks them all off wow so if you're a
veteran and you live in central florida
and you want a blow job on veterans day
all you gotta do is pull up to the
sausage castle and jenny jizz will serve
you in a room bro
it's like a room full of like 200 dudes
and this [ __ ] is just in the middle of
just no she's in the middle just serving
everybody with [ __ ] come all over her
[ __ ] face
you know what god bless you jenny jizz i
think that's her name
jizz is in it yeah either way whatever
your name is aka jane jizz
um but yeah that's dope that's dope i
couldn't do it
it could be one of those veterans and be
in a room with like 200 other dudes yeah
but but you know what imagine if you're
like 199.
you're like damn this [ __ ] has a belly
full of sperm right now oh yeah i'm at
the end of the line i showed up late
well that might get you going and she's
like there's no pressure i'm like
definitely like definitely she's
definitely like 52.
oh well that's even better and he was
telling me like her husband's there in
films at all like he gets off on that
[ __ ] most of the guys that are coming
out they're probably like insecure and
they just want to like jerk off in jenny
jizz's mouth sort of like scared and
[ __ ] and then like finally they're like
159 it's like [ __ ] yeah this is no
threat
jimmy james you know that they do that
and go eat a hamburger [ __ ] steak at
the [ __ ] [ __ ] bar they're at
afterwards
anyway no so that night michelle hey
real quick my bad cap shout out to mike
busy though because mike busey
when you meet him in person um whatever
you might think about him or his family
relations or his wild characterisms or
his dress code like he he
he's serving the uh community in a
positive way yeah thank you
blowies man i love you bro yeah no jelly
roll was there and i was like that was
the first time i met jelly shot the
jelly bro he's [ __ ] killing it no
he's killing it he's amazing it's great
to see uh
his
progression
yeah yeah and and and i've said this
about jelly roll oh look who's calling
hold on oh it's mike
oh my god you [ __ ] maniac oh dawg we
just been bigger than you
wait wait wait wait we're recording so
listen you up i was just talking about
veterans day blow jobs at your house
yeah who was jimmy james what's the
girl's name's jenny jizz right
here
just giving a little job back one one
at a time how many guys at one time mike
have you had over there on veterans day
that she sucked off
i mean we've had hundreds come over here
to celebrate the party
but
have she's sucked off in one party i
think the record's probably around like
30 35 40. they just came all at once
like as a part of a crew
well what happens is when we do it we
kind of like do it by like all right
who's had the most active years in
service if you're missing a leg or an
arm that bumps you up to the line so if
someone's amputated their amputee they
get up to the front
oh yeah purple heart that'll get you far
up until [ __ ] yeah
a [ __ ] draft dude mike man we've been
bigging you up you're the [ __ ] man
dude
we were talking about the first time i
met you was at a ritz show and that
night he stayed back and i went to your
house i was just telling him that's why
i don't
that's what
exactly what i was saying about you bro
i was like yo mike
seems like this crazy guy he's very
eccentric he's all that but he
like i can't [ __ ] with you mike because
you're a maniac you'll get me in trouble
so i was so excited to hear what went
down
at the spot and this [ __ ] was talking
about [ __ ] jenny jesus
yes
dawg thank you for your contribution
mike i love you
[Music]
yo just bro take a good look at this
guy's face
mike say hi to the camera
oh there it is there it is is he in
there
oh there he is just so you guys can see
what this crazy bastard looks like we've
been talking about your like 15 minutes
yeah mike man we really
nah let me see
nah nah man we really respect you though
bro i'm giving you love bro you're one
of the
biggest hardest dudes i know and you're
a [ __ ] maniac but like besides that
it ain't been a decade don't age me bro
2014.
hey do you remember when we went to that
trailer park in in st petersburg and lit
[ __ ] on fire in front of the [ __ ]
brandies
it takes me to the hollywood trailer
park wait wait wait mike do you remember
when i had you guys on the air and this
piece of [ __ ] had chocolate poured all
over his naked hairy body and girls
licked it off
christ
this [ __ ] eric larock had
chocolate syrup poured all over his body
live on the radio and had some girl with
daddy issues licking off his belly who
did him oh dope
we're just bringing people together
dude man you offer so much to the world
man you you get it i hope you get it
back in tenfold man i love you
all right michael you're a [ __ ]
maniac keep killing it keep cooking up
yes sir
we're coming to the sausage castle soon
hey mike when i grow some balls man i'm
gonna come to the sausage castle man i
just gotta grow man they're getting
there
uh i'll i'll be waiting for you brother
i'll be waiting for you i love you bro
all right man
[ __ ] mike busy the last night beauty
ladies and gentlemen
yeah yeah yeah yeah if you got a peg leg
if you got a purple heart
on veteran's day go go get that first in
line blowy from jenny jizz i mean who
would i mean that's kind of that's a
real contribution it is that's a real
some people need a release i mean [ __ ]
man if i wasn't like you know not to be
[ __ ] up but like if i was in a bad
situation i mean he's really offering
the service right you'd pull up i mean
oh i would pull up your goddamn right
yes
uh yo you know what's crazy is you
you've been smoking weed and i feel like
when you and i first started kicking it
you really weren't like a big like you
said you used to smoke back in the day
but at the time i feel like you really
weren't like really into smoking like
that not because like weed like so with
me it's weird it's like um it's cool you
ask that too weed is like one of those
things like back in the day
it was so weird because like i used to
be such a big weed smoker and it really
[ __ ] with me not being that anymore i
didn't know who i was you know what i'm
saying without it so then getting it
back or whatever you know just spoken it
tell you a funny ass story no so anyway
getting it back it makes me a little
paranoid yeah sometimes i'm having a
good time depends what i'm with and i
don't like that weird weird [ __ ] yeah
but that never used to be me but it is
what it is dishonesty tell you some
funny ass [ __ ] i had a video shoot
called like that
[ __ ] i don't want to butcher the name of
shout out to the guys man shout out to
my boy scotty atl man shout out to
scotty atl he just opened the grill shop
here in l.a dude i'm so proud of him
yeah he's killing it so anyway anyway it
was a it was a like a atlanta 420 song
and they had all these atlanta artists
on it
and dude i was in corey mo's house shout
out cory cory mo dude i'm in his house
and they're like you know there's 15 20
blunts around and like hey all you got
to do is make this eight ball in the
corner pocket in the shot i was so
stoned and weird
i could you couldn't hit it nah man so
finally i couldn't hit this [ __ ]
in the pocket because i was so like
well plus i've been doing all kinds of
drugs and all kinds of [ __ ] and all my
homeboys are like hey man we bout to
bounce like you're gonna leave me here
yeah it's like 50 000 people here i'm
[ __ ] stoned [ __ ]
anyway couldn't make the [ __ ] ball in
the thing finally i was about to leave
corey goes yo ritz come here
oh greg street want to talk to you on
the phone so i'm like oh no
you know what i'm saying all stone and
[ __ ] yeah and then yo check this out
this type of [ __ ] happens to me so i get
in the car i'm like oh no i'm stoned
thank god i'm out of the house
and a [ __ ] cop followed me from 285
to 85. yeah that's the type of [ __ ] that
happens to me man it is what it is yeah
look at you looking at me like well i've
never been stoned like that oh no i have
were you with me that day i freaked out
at the party with ray sinatra
oh it's something yeah you did we just
talked about the edibles no that was
different no you know i've i've but you
know what the only time i've ever been
freaked out was smoking
because that was an edible thing but
smoking
i smoked i think i i smoked sativa and i
was [ __ ] bugging bro yeah it wasn't
like i was like bugging like it's just
you lose your personality and it's like
you're just like trying to but i never
used to be like that so it was weird
like getting what's it like um
co-headlining
after leaving strange music with tech
uh it's really cool man because like um
you know just strange's family you know
right um no matter what we've been
through you know
the strange fan base is very [ __ ]
loyal
it's like ritz man we miss you like yeah
you know like i didn't go nowhere yeah
like drive [ __ ] gone no project since
i left yeah we're still friends like
everything's cool i'm just trying to
make some money for myself and just like
furthering myself in business it's like
you know you you know you rent a home to
somebody you or you're a homeowner you
try to rent like six more and you start
doing your real estate [ __ ] yeah you
dropped you've dropped four projects
since you left yeah yeah yeah put a
crown on it chris uh richmond's uh
picture price perfect and uh sos and i
got a lot more coming so it's like um
you know yeah either way it's one of
those things you dropped four projects
on strange music oh on streams no i mean
i mean i'm saying like that says a lot
like you dropped yeah two thousand times
music 18. i'm saying you dropped you
dropped the same amount of [ __ ] really
project wise
from the entire time you were on strange
for sure for sure since you've left and
those guys yeah since i left yeah for
sure
and like but it was a different game
then you know different time different
uh different way things are delivered to
the consumer and stuff um
but man the thing is that people don't
realize man you get so caught up in the
who's who and who's with what label and
who's cool who all this music [ __ ]
at the end of the day is business and
i'm i'm friends with tech and travis and
everybody on that label so i got love
for them you know what i'm saying like
so it's not like they look at this man
you left strange blah blah it's like yo
man this is business man like
like these are my friends right um
what is like for you
you know
what for people who don't know like the
success you you've had on billboard yeah
moving units like what was like the peak
for you as far as like amount of units
sold first week which album was it and
like how many how many did you sell
because i know you were in the 20s and
you were yeah yeah it was probably my
second album next to nothing um what did
that do like was it like 24 000 or
something [ __ ] up i don't even
remember i just remember it being so
important to see that billboard like
number three r b your number one
independent or no yeah it's pop or
whatever i just don't think people like
recognize the amount of like what
happened actual numbers you've done yeah
yeah i did i did some numbers they
weren't like
reading this so they were impressive
they weren't devastating yeah but they
were very impressive they were cool yeah
and and unfortunately man for me
not unfortunately actually it's just
just part of my story it's like um
i came in the game right when people
stopped buying albums so i was like they
bought your albums i was right on tail
end but i had a friend know hey i'll
tell you what we were talking about my
boy chief
this [ __ ] is shocked
he was like we went into best buy and
[ __ ] and uh
because they were on like display it was
like the last time best buy was gonna
have some [ __ ] on display
and i was like dude this [ __ ] sold like
twenty thousand he was like but you
gotta think though like one person
probably bought more than one copy so
what a dick yeah i was like what the
[ __ ] yeah then i [ __ ] with them still
about it it's still about to this date
um i feel like i feel like chief jinx
drives a challenger
or a charger
he does he does he does he does he
definitely does i do too i do zoom but
not like chief jenks but shout out to my
boy but back on the album [ __ ] though
like no rim's on it too right
i don't want to get lost all right back
under the album [ __ ] sorry back on the
album [ __ ] because my i feel like my fan
base really care about like music yeah
like there are a lot of like aspiring
artists
so um yeah it was weird like i got on
like right when it was like when you
think uh when albums are moving and
what's happening on the billboard charts
and where you rank at all this [ __ ] but
streams changed everything up and you
know things things happen
but i was very fortunate you know what
i'm saying but uh it's weird though
trying to judge yourself now
because your mindset's still there but
that's not how to be judged you know i
was gonna say hi like because i feel
like you've done a good job because i
know there was a point in time
when you left strange where you were
like man i gotta figure out this whole
streaming [ __ ] now and i feel like
the answer to that is what you're doing
well the streaming ship was like this
there's a [ __ ] your car is here and
there's a [ __ ] train coming you see
that [ __ ] train coming for a long
time then
jesus hey here you go hold on this is
great keep this [ __ ]
i hate your guts nice kid so anyway um
it's my wife
um but not so so anyway so the streaming
thing was like a train coming
and then you're parked over here but you
don't see the same train coming in
and then you try to catch up you know
what i'm saying what's going on you know
what i'm saying trying to figure it out
right um
i don't know i i'm happy with where i'm
at though you know it's it's the it's
the fans and the the people on the
outside that that that don't really know
how it works you know what i'm saying so
it's just i can't complain i feel like
the fact you just been putting out so
much catalog is like the the answer to
that you just keep feeding it you got to
drop more often now yeah for sure and
and that's what i'm and now you got the
freedom to do that because you're fully
independent yeah dude so i just i just
dropped sos which is like eight records
everybody's like yo eight records this
is not album bros ep bro and i looked up
thriller it's nine records so i'm like
thriller right now album no i think
technically uh album is more than five
yeah i don't know i don't know either
way it's a [ __ ] you call whatever the
[ __ ] you want that's what i'm saying so
either way i look at it now and you get
these music guys you know actually bro
you know an ep is actually seven records
in the lp so it's like hey [ __ ] you no
it's whatever the [ __ ] i want to call it
[ __ ]
so you know
and then um
uh but i wanted to put all hard records
on here you know send her my manager man
shout out freddie berman um you know
just hearing right here my music was
like hey we could do whatever the [ __ ]
we want right now
you did a christmas album
yeah well that hey by the way my
christmas album to this day is my
favorite body of work i ever made but
you know so we we just realized hey put
eight hard-ass records out there see
what they think we got a ton of records
backed up coming soon how'd the
christmas album do
not good and well i won't say not good
meaning oh man bomb because same thing
there's no we don't have any
expectations we're just putting it out
trying to please the fans that really
love my music you know what i'm saying
so the the weight of
numbers and all that [ __ ] it doesn't
really matter as much anymore yeah you
know what i mean because it just is what
it is
um
but yeah so the christmas album yeah it
was what it was and i forgot what the
[ __ ] we was talking about for what was
dumber you were talking about um sos and
just being just putting eight records
together that were hard as [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah so we put the christmas album
out and then um you know so it was time
to put some uh new records out so uh let
me text this [ __ ] upstairs to turn
that [ __ ] down sorry dude no that's
better because i'm [ __ ] up because i
have no idea what we're talking about
are we talking about spaceships
what were we talking about
two uh
packages hardship smooth [ __ ] coming out
in january
what that was
i don't remember
sos sos hard as [ __ ] then you got a good
new group of songs yeah yeah yeah yeah
so now it's like so now it's like i
could do whatever i want you know i
could put out a christmas album and
that's why i like the christmas album
the most because it's the most fun it's
the first time i sat down i really had
fun yeah and felt like i was a kid again
in the studio and i i had a blast all
the songs go together so if you could
look at it like a movie
but oh that's what we were talking about
we were talking about how it [ __ ] up
let me tell you how this delivery [ __ ]
up so a christmas album you really only
have a certain window right
so the guy who shot videos for me
caught coved on the way back
so the first week when the videos were
coming out he couldn't get him out
so the videos are three weeks late you
know what i'm saying are two weeks late
so i mean you only got two more weeks
before christmas is over
so you know that [ __ ] was weird that
[ __ ] [ __ ] me up the timing did you
think about just holding off until next
christmas to drop it no [ __ ] no my
personal life was going through a
[ __ ] downfall funnel goddamn cake at
the same time so it was like it was just
a big whirlwind of fuckness but um yeah
if uh but yeah we're gonna keep i i
personally think like for me the
christmas album is the best body of work
i've ever made my whole life and i've
been rapping since
1992. ritzmas
ritzman
and chris and of course chris was safe
for everybody nobody get you know what
i'm saying but it's a good um
what do you say your personal life's in
a funnel cake of [ __ ] uh
how are you doing now
well it's been crazy man like um
um you know i was doing the saturday
sobriety session doing all the [ __ ] for
sobriety i went to s known i went to
rehab got sober i did the song um
uh twin lakes uh ready for recovery it's
a great record yeah thank you man thank
you and and you know even people that
like don't understand that record this
is there's so many people that do that
make it so worth it you know what i mean
i i get it to this day um
and i did a great job man you know it
says same though but it's that alcoholic
attic [ __ ] you know you start thinking
you're cocky enough to like really no i
got this you know you [ __ ] up you know
so i relapsed i was probably like a year
and a half or even more almost close to
two years sober
relapse gotten some terrible [ __ ] to
happen and then you know i've just been
in the situation and with corona
you know with the covert [ __ ] and us um
you know quarantining and just being
stuck you know it's been a [ __ ]
but right now i'm feeling back on my
feet i'm you know what i mean so it's
getting better
it's getting better but a lot of fans
don't understand and the same thing
that's what i'm about you know i want to
be real with the fans and nobody ever
asked me you know real [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying that's what it
is you know picture perfect came out
um
you know that was cool celebrated the
christmas album came out and life went
went crazy it was just like waiting to
get back on tour again you know well you
know what's crazy is like you always
talk about like them you you touched on
this in your music like the
misconception that you're like a rich
guy
yeah yeah and like financially you've
had issues yeah and and you know what i
get that all the time like it's i'm
happy you asked me that because i get
that all the time like these guys man
you broke ass [ __ ] it's like
telling some guy like these glasses are
ten dollars and then they they're like
oh thank you so much and they go order
ten pairs and then they say that's what
you get for working them ten dollars
classes so you can't use that against me
bro you don't know my life you know also
yeah you you're very transparent yeah
very transparent and my and i want to be
transparent right now i've had some
money
here's the thing man to everybody who's
out there who's working who's an artist
who i've watched bootleg kev interview
period and y'all might not even know the
[ __ ] i am or respect what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about either way let me tell you
something
a hundred thousand dollars is a hundred
dollars
two hundred thousand it all goes away
next thing you know to be all gone
you'll be happy to get 500
you got to be careful man you know what
i'm saying and it's not you blow and
it's not like you're blowing it all on
jewelry you know crazy [ __ ] it's life
man you start thinking you're you're the
big [ __ ] you got to be consistent and
hell all of us know right now [ __ ] a
[ __ ] pandemic can come
and this how much did that cost you
oh my god dude i mean i didn't work bro
and like because you're you you do so
much live live shows i do i didn't work
so like before that happened i was
already you know in debt from
doing what i was doing and and then i
started a label you know when you when
you start a label you get an advance you
know you do all that but either way man
yeah it [ __ ] me up i mean if you got
an artist that tours right if if
everybody doesn't know me as a household
name or on the radio or what or whatever
um
yeah man it's not like you're making a
shitload of money most of your money
comes from touring hey what up man we
got to interrupt the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
odd socks now when i be riding for odd
socks so hard man it's because i really
love the product they got the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ] world i
got a pair of odd socks basics on right
now go get those they got the socks wwe
joints you know i'm saying shout out to
the undertaker pepsi [ __ ]
really whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now you want some pop tarts on
your dick
pop tart draws and these [ __ ]
are so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website
oddssocksofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview
what was um financially what was the
best year you've had off of music
uh probably around so around 2015
and just strictly from touring and not
touring you know a lot of people hit me
up and this is no dis or strange
everybody's like man if you were strange
you could be nah man when i go on my own
tours you know i make a lot of money you
know you set up tours you're selling
merchandise you're doing all this you're
getting a lot of money the problem is
even a person like
i like to consider myself somewhat
humble which might not be humble to even
say
um but um you know
i've i've i never considered myself a
baller or how much how much was the
motion in the year if you don't mind
sharing like off music
i don't know off music i know that i had
like touring music i know i had like you
know almost a half a meal in my bank
account
wow you know so it's like when you have
that
and you um
man a half it goes so fast and you went
through that [ __ ] i went through it
helping people i went through it doing a
lot for myself it wasn't like i went
through it like buying cars and houses
i went through it over time
and uh and when i say half a mil it
wasn't up that high but you know we're
around that era i mean that area but i
mean you know you can [ __ ] off your
money man try to be [ __ ] save the
world dude you can't what were the
things you learned like uh that you're
gonna try to because like i feel like
right now you're in a position to
probably make more money than you ever
have exactly exactly what are the things
that you learn that you're gonna like
try to do differently now that you're
well one don't um don't uh spend all
your time
you know spend any of your financial
investments that you've made well
actually one i'll tell i'll say this
because uh gucci said it the best and
i'm like not like a gucci [ __ ]
enthusiast or nothing like that i'm not
hating i'm just saying i heard this and
i thought it was very intelligent
if i didn't
if i didn't
the last five six years act like this
was a [ __ ] party
you know what i'm saying and really
approached it like this is business
i would have a lot of money right now
but instead i was trying to do like
trying to be
and i wasn't even buying them crazy buy
some sunglasses by like eight pairs of
j's give your homie like here's 20 grand
there's 30 grand he was passing out 20
grand to the homies
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah you're you're nice
yeah
so and but that's not
so i got to a point where i felt like i
was like
like i hope they don't hear this and
think that i'm like
you know it's my fault i did it you know
what i'm saying but yeah that's how man
you can't be man you gotta take the [ __ ]
serious there's a window you get your
[ __ ] money you save it up you know
what i'm saying don't give it away to
your friends bro well you don't do
anything with it man grow the [ __ ] up
stop partying
like yo you're making some money you
have a big career like dude it's time
it's time to look in the mirror and go
oh [ __ ] that party [ __ ] is old you know
what i'm saying it's hard as an artist
though we use it as an excuse like i'm
some creative [ __ ] drug guy
drinking yeah whatever
um but yeah but to everybody out there
man take that [ __ ] money man
save it give it to your family give it
to your mom and dad to hold give it to i
don't know figure it out dude because
you only got so much time and you can
make a lot of money doing this [ __ ]
what are your thoughts on this
weird
and you know it's it's funny because
for people who like like obviously for
people who know like you and i have a
long history
and that stems from my relationship with
yellow wolf back in the day yeah
um but what are your thoughts
what are your thoughts on um what are we
doing this way oh
this [ __ ]
white maga rap [ __ ] that's popping right
now
it's [ __ ]
terrible in my opinion
it's weird right so like
so
my homie burton um
was a who's absolute dog [ __ ]
well i i can't i can't join them with
that because just i'm just i'm i
he's an atrocious
atrocious artist anyway continue no no
that's that's fine i i can't join in
only because the same thing i you know
i'm a friend man they
i was happy to see his numbers go up you
know what i'm saying i saw his numbers
because you would work with that guy
like back in the day before he was on
that work with him and i knew him as a
like not knowing him as a person like
we're boys but like knew him it's like
backs i i just you know if i meet
somebody and i get along with him i get
along with him
you know
so i saw what he was doing and i was
happy to see his numbers going up
doing what he's doing
and i like and i'm using him only as an
example he's he's the type of guy
birdman stop that [ __ ] he's the type
of god that'd be like be happy i'm
talking about him on here like oh [ __ ]
i'm about to get you know but now this
is real [ __ ] like i like this kid like
like not kid like i like this guy like
he's a good guy
and i'm happy his numbers are growing
but the thing is man
and this is not the same yeah it's just
i don't know man i'm so disappointed in
the human race
with all this [ __ ] [ __ ] man and i
don't want to say trump [ __ ] to get
people mad at me like oh ritz is all
left liberal it's like no
just understandable you know what i'm
saying i'm just i understand like if you
were to sit here and be like yo
i love the mega white boy rap
you're my friend so i'm not gonna hate
you right right
you know what i'm saying i just wish
more people would develop that mindset
of just being a little bit more
understanding but yeah as far as rap
goes what you're asking and i know
you're
see this bootleg kev he's addicted he'll
ask you these questions to get the real
out of you and he's he's that's all he's
sitting there waiting on yeah but you
don't quit being a [ __ ] and answer the
question so
yes
i [ __ ] hate
the [ __ ] way the state of the
country's in with all this [ __ ] and
i hate that it's in hip hop yo man this
is black music this is black music man
period
this is what the [ __ ] has been a lot of
[ __ ] has been going down and and
everybody on that other side
is tripping and it's been [ __ ] up for
a long time y'all are tripping to use
rap music as a quote as a as a sales
pitch for this [ __ ] music y'all are
[ __ ]
tripping yeah my thing is that's what
i'm saying real quick my bad care
because a lot of people might eat me up
over that and i don't have like i don't
want to piss anybody off but this is
hip-hop
you know what i'm saying and you know
what
what that side stands for
for the most part
and not that everybody and i'm
understandable doesn't it and i'm open
to independent thinkers i'm open to all
that i'm just saying no but don't let's
not use rap music i can't care what you
feel like in regular society that's fine
but rap music it's black music and when
you're using your music to [ __ ] on black
lives matter
and the push and the push blue lives
matter and police i'm like bro
someone get these people to [ __ ] up out
of here like man this is rap music
that's it i'm just a hipaa i'll just
leave it as simple as that i'm hip-hop
bro and that [ __ ] ain't cool
but
to my friends it's low-hanging fruit for
these [ __ ] because they get
such easy numbers because there's all
these people who at the same time though
let's be honest it's not their [ __ ]
fault there's a whole society here
that's the last that's consuming the
music to have them yeah i mean obviously
it's working for someone let's not like
like let me not [ __ ] on them like
they're terrible human beings there's a
whole they're just terrible rappers
there's a whole society cat that i don't
disagree obviously there's an entire
part there's they have fans i know you
don't disagree i'm just saying like
that's how weird it is now right you
know it's strange bro and you know it's
gonna be even more shrines a year from
now kev's got one of them on there and
he's on this show right now i'm sitting
he's like dude
for real i feel you right now dude cause
like never
brushed like you know caskey's the homie
of mine and like
he'd be beefing with these [ __ ]
weirdos and i'm like bro
who the [ __ ] cares what adam calhoun has
to say this guy literally is dropping n
bombs on records
look see this is like
just goofy ass [ __ ] like
he tries to start [ __ ] let me tell you
something i don't know adam calhoun
i i know cass i don't know him either i
just know that his music is dog [ __ ] i
know burton and burton's a friend of
mine i like him a lot i think he's a
nice guy
um he makes bad music i wish him the
best though i i
but and i like caskey i don't know adam
calhoun it's just such a weird it's like
it's like this weird white rap rapper
like thing going on that's like
developed the last few years crazy and
you know what you know what's [ __ ] up
though i mean do we look at it as a
society thing or do we look at yeah
business it's both yeah but these i mean
because they're taking advantage of of a
portion of society that wants to hear
that [ __ ]
no i i know i get that i'm not saying
like if it's bad business i'm just
saying like it's it's a weird time man
well it sucks too because i feel like
people look at me like they might talk
about this more than that talk about my
skills right compare me and do you know
it's just it's unfortunate for somebody
that really tries and loves making music
right that's the main part because i
don't i don't look on [ __ ] um
google in the morning and see what's
popular with the [ __ ] president no
one gives a [ __ ] man let me tell y'all
something man no one gives a [ __ ] i grew
up on martin bro
martin and living color the race shit's
been figured out
it like we all cool we're all trying to
work when we taking so many steps
backwards this [ __ ] is whack as [ __ ] i
don't know where i was going at but i
grew up in a different era man ain't
with this [ __ ] man i like sure yeah
i don't want to hear this [ __ ] man
just i want to hear some hip hop i want
to hear some [ __ ] spit
but either way um
how did you speaking of [ __ ]
spitting
yeah you were talking about earlier uh
before we were filming how successful
the record with vinnie pass has been
jedi mind tricks obviously legendary
independent
yeah movement like vinnie bad how did
you guys end up linking up it was crazy
because like um i never met vinny paz
and i i met him at uh i finally met him
at soldier field we did a show in
soldier field with like crucial conflict
and he passed like
there was a crooked eye all these people
like it was cool and it was so dope and
i didn't wear chicago jersey that night
because i had like it was like when
baseball jerseys was in style and [ __ ]
like two years ago
i thought everybody would have one on
but no one did i could have worn one on
stage but either way
either way
i did this [ __ ] show
and uh man vinnie just showed so much
love
i'm gonna be completely honest like back
in the day like i was not in the
backpack rap like like what we called it
right right back in the day yeah the
boom back way back i'm talking about two
thousand one two thousand boom
jokes and you know when i hear names
like jedi mind tricks i didn't know so
once i got on on like 2010 man i studied
vinnie pass i went back and listened to
who he was and how amazing he was you
know so when i met him in person he
showed me a lot of respect and was just
a great guy and uh yeah shout out to c
lance he lance made that happen um sea
lance producers for a lot of people man
um
uh mercury's and and plus ogs in the
game um but yeah so that vinnie pads
record was dope man he was it was cool
but i tell you what though the reason i
say that about jedi mind tricks is
because it just goes to show how you can
totally
disrespect something as a young kid who
knows nothing and later on learn who the
[ __ ] you're talking about and how dope
somebody is you know what i'm saying so
like yeah vinnie pass bless me man oh
that's big man yeah um how's your
current relationship with wolf i haven't
taught the wolf man i think when's the
last time you talked
um i think i talked to him like uh i
think the last time we talked was when i
did uh the box chevy video shoot that
never came out like uh 2019. wow so over
two years about two years yeah but but
um
so yeah he never ended up putting that
my back
he never ended up putting that video out
but um
uh then i then i went to rehab
and then you know we might have covered
and it just got covered yeah so it's
just i haven't talked to him man you
know i saw he did the project with
caskey i've been listening to his music
i saw he put out all these records he
put out like four albums in a month yeah
what what was this bane album's name not
to be like what was this uh
either way his last album that he that
he put out
that [ __ ] was this [ __ ] man he
always has these great man you know i
was just a little i was like we've been
waiting for a ritz
wolf or a brits big crate album all this
time and he puts an album out with
riffraff
yeah yeah like
hey i will say this though i will say
this with that and and roof rafts to the
homies you know good yeah but can i say
this this would be good this is perfect
time
i'm getting a little and this has
nothing to do with yellow wolf and riff
raff nothing i'm talking about period
i'm a little tired of the collab [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] off everybody everybody
it seems like everybody's like yo collab
project and it seems almost fake now so
we could get bigger numbers right right
like we all me and you're a fan of each
other we should do a bootleg kev ritz
yeah i mean that would be real though
cause we're fine
but you know all these [ __ ]
meet each other it's like hey man i'll
collab clap clap clap clap
but i tell you funny story one night i
forgot that somebody asked me to do a
collab and i was speaking to him like
i'm speaking you know about my
frustration with that and i forgot he
asked about it i was like oh
my bad man who is it oh no i'm not going
to say it because it's my good friend
good friend and i'd love to collab with
him
but yo
[ __ ] off with your collab projects man
[ __ ] off man i'm gonna do something i'm
gonna do something because i gotta
conform to you guys who would you do
something but i'm sick of everybody oh
[ __ ]
[ __ ] off man make some music man
there it is who would uh i mean i know
you had spoken before about like maybe
doing like uh
doing some [ __ ] like that i think we're
like yo twisted would be crazy there's
like twister would be crazy devin the
dude oh my god oh man
the main people you know what's [ __ ]
up i was thinking with interviews there
was like some r b [ __ ] that
like
i would really love to go in with but
like i forgot like you know what it was
about what happened in ikea
i don't know how well real quick before
i get i am a doobie fan dubies
that's the homie i'm gonna do it he
records here a lot i'm a doobly fan of
his music no he's incredible i like his
music i like it i like doing dj
highlight shout out to the whole oh
shout out dude
the whole crew i just yeah
you know i'm talking about music no
doobie's a alien
fan yeah he's cool and he does that that
new [ __ ] but he does it like great he's
a great he's a great great writer great
artist man he's dope bro shout out to
the doobie man he's a wild boy he's the
one who introduced me to the term tongue
punch her fart box oh that's crazy yeah
that's that's a lot it's a lot
yeah i guess maybe i've done that too
many times for that phrase to really
affect me
yeah
would you like would you uh if dude was
like yo let's do ep would you be down oh
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you like somebody like
what i don't want to do is do an ep like
where we have to like measure our dicks
and see who raps faster i don't want
nothing to do with that you know what
i'm saying and i don't want to force
anything with anybody else that's like
you know just because we're friends and
we think it'll make some money
you know i'm saying we're talking about
jelly roll earlier um philly bro hey yo
let's talk about him man cause jelly's
been on a run
and i feel like
he had played me a song in like 2014
called sunday morning
yeah so what's crazy is he played me
that record when i was living in tampa
and it wasn't out yet yeah we were
that's that run we went on and i was
like uh
bro
i know you rap and [ __ ] but like yeah do
that because that record is crazy i'm
happy to talk about jelly roll because
um and that's exactly
because we were in the same state same
situation
that's exactly when i remembered like um
you know he's got something he's
starting to find
what he's supposed to be but then i was
shopping at kroger one day and i heard
this sunday morning on the [ __ ] thing
i didn't know it was somebody else's
record
all right it's a sample yeah oh okay but
he [ __ ] murdered it so much he made
it sound like but he sounds so good
singing i was like bro whatever it is
you sound like i'm saying that because
like
that was the beginning of to to me where
i saw him go now so now he's not only
that was a sample of this sunday morning
but he's making these classic man he's a
great
save me is like one of the most like one
of my favorite songs in years i mean
let's just say that it's just gold jelly
roll i love you um thank you for not
calling your album hip-hop this year
because uh you would have knocked me out
the spot yo man dude i'm so proud of you
yo man for real like his album his
writing he's a great writer now he's a
beast and and crazy probably the coolest
person i've met in music i'm so proud of
the best personality whenever they put
that [ __ ] in movies and tv shows
and give him his own podcast it's over
dude i'm so proud of him and his wife's
got a dope podcast too shout out to his
wife buddy all i just know is man he's a
great dude and he's been at it for a
long time and the fact that you're doing
this now like
[ __ ] that's crazy because he was like a
nashville white boy rapper like i think
you used to like associate him with
haystack back in the day yeah that's me
hope man you know that's what you want
to be like that just means that you
could be that and after so many years
think that this is where it's gonna be
you're doing 500 cat i mean wolf told me
that man you'll be doing 500 cat rooms
for the rest of your life [ __ ]
so he told me you know what i'm saying
make it man make it the kind of music
you make
but it just goes to show man nah there's
time bro you just gotta tap in
jelly roll tapped in and he's been
[ __ ] killing it so i'm proud of him
you know what i mean uh it's it's it's
it's a beautiful day this is [ __ ]
crazy man
it's dope it's dope um i i do get
annoyed with people telling me i'm in
that country rap language no no but
you're not but i don't know you don't do
that at all and jelly man i've signed so
many t-shirts with your face on it out
here with his tourists he says you know
jelly roll was supposed to be on the
tour
oh i know i remember but he had another
obligation and then two years or a year
and a half from barclays covey no he
originally was supposed to be on the
channel i'm just straight signing tech
and jelly roll shirts on this tour
and people come up to me like dude i
came here to see jelly but man dude
you'll [ __ ] do bud i mean this will
work out
hell yeah yo
what what is like um
you've done the gathering of the
juggalos right oh my god yes shout out
to the
whoop
whoop
what was that my boy ouija what was that
like it's [ __ ] insane first time i
ever went there right i told a story
before so i'll tell some like other dude
so first time we pulled in there's this
like big ass girl naked as [ __ ] just
sitting on a dude's face riding his face
like just
[ __ ] all on his [ __ ] mustache like
how big
yeah
it's hard to measure girls like what 250
nice little [ __ ]
[ __ ] what's her name goddamn
tammy
god damn time he was going to pull into
the gathering of the juggalos and
there's a fat white woman right in the
face and some dude's just sitting there
yeah
like a kitten with a can of tuna and
[ __ ]
so yeah so yeah so we saw that
and then there was like this drug bridge
or like where or oh no there was a raw
dog tent where you go in there and [ __ ]
the girl with no rubber
and like yeah the raw dog tent with now
this is before they change their whole
[ __ ] wait wait mind you i've never been
this is yo shout out to all the juggalos
out there man you guys showed me so much
love i'm just not gonna front and act
like i knew what the [ __ ] was going on
wait wait wait wait the raw dog tent
um so what is like there's one girl
who's just in there getting [ __ ] wrong
that's what i heard i never obviously
stepped into the raw dog tent so it's
just a [ __ ] who's just
yeah like you've got a [ __ ] with no
rubber and you you know you go in there
and just dog her out everybody's coming
in there
you know it's the raw dog tent
go in there and raw dog and there's a
drug bridge
yo [ __ ] was crazy back then i remember
seeing the ghetto boys perform there you
know it's my favorite group of all time
like dude i told you i met mike tonight
oh my god so like ghetto boys do i seen
ghetto boys performing there but these
[ __ ] juggalo ass white boys they have
no idea they had some but yeah not like
man i i i hated i wanted to go up there
man this [ __ ] ghetto boy
but they ain't giving [ __ ] about me
either you're upset so i'm watching this
[ __ ] but yeah that [ __ ] is wow dude
that's just crazy raw dog tent and the
drug bridge is like a bridge that you
could just go like you know yeah
get your heroin get your meth right and
but so this is how
i'm sure everyone was on meth well
that's how tricky that [ __ ] is because i
could talk about it in like a million
these [ __ ] just me so juggalos
i love you i don't know about raw dog
tent
or all that i've heard and i've also
seen and y'all [ __ ] are crazy i
will say this though
at my parents house
my mom and dad's house they have on
their cable they have the juggalo
channel on their what's it roku there's
a juggalo channel yes and they have the
[ __ ] gathering and i got the saw and
i was like oh [ __ ] i know them yo you
get to see like them like dancing and
[ __ ] and twerking and [ __ ] yeah on a
juggalo channel on [ __ ] roku with all
due respect
you gotta watch this tonight
nah i'm good man dude you you might like
it i always say that icp
fans
with all due respect
are the ugliest [ __ ] fans in
all the hip-hop
see this why this [ __ ] is going
to get me in trouble no i'm not i'm just
saying i've been to some icp shows
and them juggalettes
they're just not the ones you know what
i'm saying i mean you know what's crazy
is like i heard all these like rumors
they look like my aunts what's [ __ ] up
is when you
what's
stupid is that what's [ __ ] up is when
you go on stage like man you don't know
they might they're supposed to throw
like bottle rockets at you they hit you
with [ __ ] if they don't like you
blah blah like when you even when
they're happy even when they like your
song like
it sounds like they're booing and [ __ ]
and like it's it's [ __ ] it's a crazy
experience and now there's like 45 year
old
teachers in high school yeah with
hatchet man tattoos that they got when
they were 18. i mean let's not get me
wrong i mean the nudity is cool i mean
there's a lot of oblong titties and a
lot there's a lot of long titties
there's a lot of long tails there's a
lot of stretch marks with some [ __ ]
lime green on them [ __ ] you know
congratulations you know like you go to
a fortune you go to a 420 show and it
smells like weed i feel like if you went
to the gathering of the juggalos it
would smell like meth smoke
no
it really has a mess being blown in the
air nah nah it really doesn't it really
does it smells like like fago like nbo
soda
now i'm backstage to be honest i go on
there and i just hope that i don't get
hit with none
straight up i'm like just show them love
and like yo but i did tour with icp i
toured with them 2019 and uh so that was
i mean you know what's crazy is i'd love
to interview those guys because i feel
like
while i think that their fans are
interesting to me
uh aesthetically
not the most pleasing uh but i respect
their
i feel like they're truly
pioneers
in this rap [ __ ] and i mean that with
all due respect they literally showed
everyone the way and i and like
and that's to say like everyone like the
merch game the indie game like they were
the first [ __ ] to really
dive in and monetize their fan base in a
way that no one else was doing oh man so
like it was salute to them icp are
legends i never was into their [ __ ] like
my cousin used to bump the great malinko
all the time and yeah my other cousin
used to work for the cottonmouth king so
i would always go to congress
but like
you know they they
mastered monetizing their fan base and
so many people use their blueprint to
this day yeah yeah for sure i mean you
know what you know what's [ __ ] up i'm
getting to the point in my career where
it's like
even if it's something that and this is
has nothing to do with icp but it's just
like even if something i'm not into i
respect it and try to figure out how it
works me too me too for sure for sure
for sure you know why it worked who
likes it why is going on some of this
shit's weird i can't feel it i'd be
doing the same [ __ ] if there's some [ __ ]
i don't understand i'll be like let me
at least understand even what i don't
understand let's get this [ __ ] out to
wait and i was just kidding i don't
understand his influence or [ __ ] like
who's the influencer the the one on
tick-tock with dan who who makes these i
don't understand it's not for us man but
that's me that's just how i feel i don't
understand certain things but i'll try
to i'll try to learn it but that [ __ ]
ain't for us brushes for the kids and
you know if like well maybe you're not
jerking off the tick tock enough at
night i'm not
clearly i mean maybe you know yeah maybe
what's the weirdest thing you've jerked
off to this month
or this year
oh man dude
i don't know
probably a picture of your cousin
[Laughter]
[Music]
i mean i couldn't find your aunt on
facebook so i mean her name is wendy
scruggs
christ now i'm in trouble and you know
what [ __ ] this [ __ ] keep that [ __ ] hey
yo shout out to my guy ritz uh so uh
[ __ ] ass sos just came out
um
now you said you kind of got like a
horse over there a whole nother project
that's like yeah kind of more of like
the like the traditional writ sound
that's kind of ready to go you know
what's great kev that you asked me that
because the thing is this these
[ __ ] been asking me all kinds
of questions online not these
[ __ ] but like people that are
hating or whatever right but
it's like yo the art of the interview is
very rare right right you know you're
giving one right now and ask me cool
questions like that so people can
actually hear it but like i no one knows
what the [ __ ] my album's about because
there's no one to ask about it you know
what i'm saying i put out eight hard
records
um sos is about help man it seems like
some therapy [ __ ] something you need to
get off your chest man it's just me
going [ __ ] hard man these
[ __ ]
not these [ __ ] but how i feel
about the industry and the consumer and
myself
society all the [ __ ] man the music
is just coming out
and so i wanted to put something really
hard out there and also with the deep
[ __ ] and i got a ton of music coming man
a bunch of [ __ ] sos is just where i'm at
my life man it's it's help you know what
i'm saying is it's showing where i'm at
and you know going through a rough time
with certain things uh
going back on that you know what i mean
no it's crazy you want to bump a coke
because you look like you're yawning
it's been i had to get my kids to school
this morning oh for people who don't
know this is being filmed at 1 am do you
want a little bump in the morning i've
never kissed you i've never drive to
school i've never done cocaine ritz yeah
right man this [ __ ] did so much
cocaine with me one day that's not true
really think about that hey can i tell a
story can't tell a story yeah but i've
never done coca-cola
so there's a random guy we're not gonna
mention his name okay
dude he's in the room with me right this
[ __ ] never done coke in his life
okay i'm not proud of this [ __ ]
but i was like i scooped a bunch up on a
key and i was like nah man you're good
you're good he's standing right there in
front i go tap
[ __ ] line just spread across
spread across his [ __ ] mouth he
[ __ ] swallowed it got all geeked up
he was all mad trying to fight me that
night someone you interviewed who
interviewed you know my friend oh your
friend does not do coke he's totally
against it i just was like no here dude
just [ __ ] with him pat
[ __ ] went directly on it's funny because
a few of my friends that i brought
around you uh
have done cocaine with you just because
they thought it was like that's the move
doing like weed with snoop yeah yeah it
is basically like i was like in austin
texas with my guy baby joel and he did a
bump with you in the back of the bus
while wearing a macho man t-shirt
and he was like [ __ ] it
ralph it's been years
yeah with ritz you know what's [ __ ] up
and he always tells me hey remember when
we were in austin with ritz and i did
that cocaine and the bus rally yeah man
yo straight up though to answer that
like
that is
damn near worth more than a million
dollars man that's amazing you know what
i'm saying that's crazy because i could
just be me just somebody in my
neighborhood during the bar hey how how
did how did was it dope to finally get
the white jesus records on the dsps with
the with the uh
the you know you kind of put them out
with the two separate releases i was in
rehab
i was in rehab doing that so yeah that
was shout out to freddie berman my
manager man who really really did that
man i was in rehab yeah cause then that
was like yo a lot of those records like
you gotta go on that path to listen to
yeah yeah yeah he put that out man you
know it was a thing and now he really
helped help me down while i was in there
and really that really kept
that really kept me going man i see
people with them t-shirts on man like
that [ __ ] was crazy because i was gone i
had nothing doing the record that really
didn't make it was the intro right yeah
because the [ __ ] funeral sample right
yeah the funeral march is [ __ ]
copyrighted um yeah that was a [ __ ]
that's a great yeah i think so of course
everybody's like hey man [ __ ] you for
not putting white jesus and i was kid
let me get mad
well you know what's funny that that
video wasn't even on youtube i think it
was on venmo
no not venmo what was the name of that
what so vimeo vimeo yeah vimeo the video
was on vimeo i remember watching our
video you know what it was was and i i
don't want to disrespect the dude who
shot it man um but uh
i don't know what the [ __ ] happened to
him i ain't talked to him but um wolf
like half like directed it
and um
man it ran for a while and that
[ __ ] took the video off the
channel oh wow and just was gone yeah
and that's why i'm scared of samples too
like dude when i put out angry johnny
like it was my first time with a sample
they gave me they were like yo one more
try youtube is gone
yeah so we were like on probation for
like three months plus when i was hey yo
this is another thing it's important to
say on your outlet whether it makes it
or not but hey man
the [ __ ] youtube thing is crazy
[ __ ] don't realize dog from
2012 to 2019
i couldn't build a youtube because of
strange contractually yeah and that's
contract contractually they had all your
videos yeah so that's not a bad thing i
understand like yeah i could have had a
guy filming me day to day trying to add
content but i have money like that right
you know what i'm saying so now you know
trying to build that youtube up people
were like people would look at you like
dude your videos don't get the views
like they used to yeah [ __ ]
because it's about subscribers you know
what i'm saying yeah you don't have the
bass that yeah all your videos are on
strange you have to build it you have to
build it man people don't be knowing the
game you know what i mean well there it
is man um so i'm assuming we're going to
get another body of work soon
we are dude you're about to get a body
of work after this [ __ ] interview's
over